[Music]
in this video you will learn how to
troubleshoot and resolve google
kubernetes engine or gke private cluster
creation failures
gke private cluster is a type of cluster
that contains nodes with only internal
ip addresses this enables users to run
their nodes within their private network
and provide better protection to
workloads with no direct exposure to the
internet let's begin by jumping into the
google cloud console and creating a gke
private cluster typically gke private
clusters are created in a shared vpc
project for this demo we will use a
project called my shared vpc dash
project which is pre-configured with the
following shared vpc network named
sharednet and a subnet in australia
southeast 1 region part and service ip
ranges service project called gke dash
service test project where we will be
creating the gke private cluster
next the service accounts of project gke
service desk project are configured with
iam role compute network user to enable
access to shared vpc submit called
sharednet next step is to create the gke
private cluster for this in the google
cloud console switch to the project
where you want the cluster to be created
in our case this is the project gke
service dash project go to kubernetes
engine clusters page click create
choose
gke standard specify the name of the
clusters as private cluster choose
location australia dash southeast one
go to the networking tab choose the
shared network and subnet in our example
we will select share net for both these
options under network access select
private cluster
you can choose to enable disable option
access control plane using its external
ip address based on your requirements
next specify the ip range for control
plane ip range remember to ensure that
these ip ranges do not conflict with
existing network ranges in advanced
networking options select the
pre-configured pod and service ip ranges
once again ensure that these ip ranges
are not already used by other clusters
in the same project finally click on
create button to create the cluster we
will now check if the cluster is created
click on the cluster name private
cluster
you can see the cluster is still being
created
oops the cluster creation failed with an
error this error indicates that out of
three nodes none of them could be
registered
it also suggests we check vm serial logs
for errors and the likely cost could be
the nodes fail to start to investigate
this error let's check the serial
console logs for one of the failing
nodes click on nodes
and node poll
under the instance group section click
on one of the instance groups
click on one of the
google compute engine or gce virtual
missions vms
under the logs section click on serial
port 1 console
in the vm console logs you can observe
the following errors the logs indicate
that nodes fail with a connection
timeout error when trying to download
required objects from the cloud storage
api
storage.googleapis.com this can happen
if the network access to
storage.googleapis.com
is not provided to resolve this issue
since this is a private cluster the two
most common ways to allow the nodes to
communicate with services such as google
apis is either by enabling private
google access on the subnet for the node
network or
enabling cloudnet
go to the networking settings of the
cluster and access the subnet of the
shared vpc project
oops we see that private google access
settings are not enabled by default
in this case let's use private google
access to enable the nodes to reach
services like storage.gov
let's enable it by turning on private
google access
as we just resolve node connectivity to
storage.googleaps.com
we can wait for some time for the nodes
to be registered otherwise recreate the
cluster in this case i have recreated
the cluster congratulations we have now
successfully created the gke private
cluster to avoid these issues
remember
to enable private google access manually
for shared vpc clusters before creating
gke private clusters unless you are
using cloudnet or other options to
connect to storage.googleapis.com
ensure that you have completed the
requirements before creating a private
cluster for more information on how to
troubleshoot gke private cluster
creation issues check out the
documentation thanks for watching
[Music]